Today,
I'd like to welcome Richard Harris to
come up and speak with us about his new
book rigor Mortis.
Um,
I've always had a kind of
passing curiosity as to, uh,
why we're not getting, um, you know,
it's the same kind of super
advancements in medicine that, um,
kind of expected us to have
by this century. And, uh,
it turns out Richard's
written an excellent book to
explain some of the reasons
why and, uh, I'm excited to welcome
here to Google to talk to us today.
I thank you all very much for coming in.
Uh,
having lunch over a topic that's a
little bit uncomfortable maybe for some
people, but maybe not.
The people in this crowd,
a biologist are not always
happy to hear this news,
although I think a lot of
them acknowledged that this
is a significant problem
and they're in there worrying
about. So, uh, let me, uh, uh,
spend a few minutes sort of
just giving you a sense of, of,
of how the book came about and, and some
of the highlights of the book. And, um,
this, I've been at NPR for coming up 31
years now and I've covered practically
everything in science and in
medicine and related fields,
environment I had over that time.
And in 2014 my boss said, hey,
we want to switch things
around a little bit.
Would you mind going back and covering
biomedicine for awhile again? And I said,
oh, that's fine, I'm happy to do that.
And I realized I was a little bit out of
touch with what had been going on since
I last paid attention in the,
around the 2000 [inaudible] late 1990s.
So the first thing I did was I
said, well, let's see how, let's,
let's take a look at the broader
trends in biomedicine. And one thing,
the first thing I discovered was
a money is a problem. Uh, this,
the, the lower graph there shows
how much funding has decreased in,
in inflation adjusted terms since the
year 2003 for NIH funded research.
Uh,
but this graph actually only tells half
the story because if you actually look
back before 2003,
between 1998 and 2003,
the NIH budget had doubled.
And so there was a huge cash infusion
for the increase of vibratory space in
this country, about 50% for this
kind of research in academia.
Just enormous growth. And
then Congress said, okay,
we've taken care of biomedicine,
we'll hold the dollars more or less flat.
But in terms of, uh, terms
of spending power, uh,
it was declining rather substantially.
So a whole bunch of more mouths to feed
and less and less money to do it. So,
so I thought that's going to have some
sort of negative consequence for sure.
The second thing I fairly quickly came
across was this paper which was published
in nature. Actually in 2012.
Uh, Glenn Begley and Lee Ellis,
uh,
wrote a paper that caught a lot of people
by surprise or certainly caught their
attention.
And what they had done was a lowly Alice,
I'm not leaving Ellis Glen Begley a
was head of cancer research for Amgen.
Big Company out in, in
the La area. And uh,
they rely very heavily on the output of
academic labs to get leads for new drugs.
And over the years,
lots of stuff had come across the
transom and most of it didn't pan out.
And Begley was sort of saying, okay,
I'm kind of wrapping up my time here,
but I want to go back one more time
and look at some of the most promising
studies and take one more run at them
and see if I can get them to work.
And so he selected 53 studies that he
thought if these studies were really
panned out, these were, these would
be very strong leads for new drugs.
So he tried to retest
them in his own labs. Uh,
most often he couldn't get them to work.
He even took them back to the
original academic labs to say,
we couldn't get this to work,
can you? And, and very often the,
the scientists there couldn't
get it to work either.
So in the end of these 53 studies,
you only got six to work.
It's about 11%. Right? Very,
very poor success rate of just replicating
a study that had been published in
the literature that people hadn't
paid a lot of attention to.
One of these papers had 2000 citations
people saying, look at this great result.
And he couldn't replicate it.
It was a similar study done the
previous year by scientists at bear in,
in Germany. And they also came up
with a pretty low success rate,
about 25% of the studies that
they were able to replicate.
So this led to this idea of
the reproducibility crisis,
uh, that was just bubbling up as a
result of these papers and similar work.
So I realized I've got a book in this
and, uh, uh, and I decided to, um,
uh,
to take some,
take a year off of NPR and dig into these
issues to really try to understand the
consequences of this. And, uh,
one of the first things I was worried
about was we'll anyone want to talk to me
about this, uh, in the
answer, surprisingly,
was people were completely happy to talk
to me about this. And, uh, for example,
this is a,
uh,
Janet Woodcock who's the number one
person at the FDA in charge of drug
approvals. And she said, I'm happy to
talk to you. This is a big problem.
And I sat down with her and we had a
long conversation and she said, you know,
the stuff we get from pharmaceutical
companies is reasonably good.
We can rely on a fairly heavily,
but if academics come directly to
the FDA with studies that it's,
the, the quality of those
studies is very, very poor.
And the quote that she has is, uh, uh,
she says it's like nine out of 10
airplanes we designed fell out of the sky,
or nine out of 10 bridges we
build failed to stand up. I mean,
this is the failure rate she's talking
about for the academic studies trying to
lead to drug development in a fairly
advanced area because they're already at
the FDA at that point.
[inaudible] you know, she,
she sort of laughed and disbelief
and said, we need rigorous science.
We can rely on another person
who was quite surprisingly, uh,
engaged in this topic. Oh,
should is Francis Collins,
who's the director of the National
Institutes of health. And to his credit,
he recognized this as a problem
early on and said, you know,
we can't sweep this under the rug.
It's clearly,
it's an embarrassment to the
enterprise that he's funding.
But his take was we got to fix
this and we can and we will,
we'll try to engage on these
issues as opposed to saying,
oh, nothing to see here,
move along. Uh, and he
engaged his top deputy, uh,
Larry Tabak to be the point
person for this issue. They both,
they worked on it together a lot and,
and among other things they wrote in,
in one of the, one of the journals,
uh, uh, Collins explained. Yeah,
of course science is self correcting.
That's the beauty of the scientific
method is that things that you don't get
everything right the first time.
It shouldn't be expected.
But there's a process that
eventually things are, you know,
mistakes are discovered.
You know,
blind blind alleys are identified
and the process corrects itself.
And so he says in the long run,
science of self correcting, but,
and here's the quote in the shorter term,
the checks and balances that once ensured
scientific fidelity have been hobbled.
Pretty strong words for the,
uh,
to come out of the mouth of the head of
the National Institutes of health. And,
uh, but you know, he is engaged on this
topic and he's taking it very seriously.
And I think that is that that probably
helped me talk to a bunch of other people
who were also very concerned
about it. And, uh, and,
and I think that's a good sign that
people are engaged in that way.
So what difference does this make? This
is a, uh, you'll appreciate this graph.
It's called e rooms law of the
inverse of Moore's law, uh,
because this is the shows that drug
development, unlike microchips, uh,
costs more and more to develop and you
get less and less bang for the buck as
time goes by. You can see in the 1950s
at the beginning of that graph, uh,
it was relatively inexpensive. That's
a log scale, uh, to develop, uh, drugs.
But you know, by 2010 things where, you
know, costing a huge amount of money for,
to yield a single drug.
And as we know,
a lot of those drugs are
fairly marginally effective.
So even if they pass muster, a lot
of these anticancer drugs are, uh,
so modest and what they achieve a,
that if you look at the national
statistics for cancer mortality,
you actually don't,
you can't even see the effect of
all of these new cancer drugs on,
on cancer mortality trends in this
country as yet. You know, maybe,
maybe we will eventually, but
at this point for all the,
all the great talk about,
uh, how much all this cancer
research is panning out.
The reality is it's costing a lot of
money and it's not yielding a whole lot of
results.
And that's a serious problem.
This is not necessarily driven
by reproducibility, but the,
but it underlines the fact that we really
need to make sure that we are being as
effective as we can in,
in working on these underlying
science projects to make sure that,
that actually to inflect this curve so
it doesn't get worse and worse and worse.
So how bad is it? Well,
what nature nature asked,
is there a reproducibility crisis and
a f and in a survey last year and a 52%
said yes,
there is a significant reproducibility
crisis and other 38% yet said there's a
yes, there's a slight crisis. Not exactly
sure what a slight crisis is, but,
but we can't say it's only 10%
said, I don't know. I don't care.
And I don't think that
this is a real issue. So,
so clearly scientists recognize this is,
this is a real,
as very significant issue and something
that they need to deal with and they're
thinking about it. Uh, uh, this, I,
this plays out in news coverage as well.
This is a paper that was in, uh, uh,
one of the plos journals, uh, published
just a couple of months ago after,
after my book went to press.
This is a team of scientists at the
University of Bordeaux that asked the
question, uh, how, how much
can we rely, for example, on,
on newspaper reports of,
of scientific discoveries.
And these did a survey of a database of
almost 200 English language newspapers.
And they said,
how well do these uh,
newspapers cover these results and how
accurate does it turn out to be in the
long run? And they identified
156 studies that, uh,
that had been reported on sometime in the
past. And they went back and they said,
okay, uh, did these studies can out?
And there are things like, you know,
linking pesticides to Parkinson's disease
or suggesting a mechanism for Adhd or
looking at,
you know,
potential new genes or putative new genes
for breast cancer and various other,
you know, things that you see. We opened
up the paper new gene for breast cancer.
Well,
it turns out that if that's 156 studies
that had actually had enough followup
that there was a, a reasonable amount of
data till sort of be able to look back.
About half of them were, uh, uh,
stood the test of time and the other
half turned out to be ephemeral. They,
the bubble burst and the idea went away.
Uh,
and if you look at these sort of those
for the first time kinds of studies where
people are just looking at the exciting
new first time anyone has seen this,
only about a third of those who are
confirmed in these further studies.
So I started thinking, I the
bottom of my stories, I should,
if I'm doing stories of this
nature, I should say, by the way,
about half the time to two thirds of the
time these studies turn out not to be
true. So are you feeling lucky
today as a sort of a warning to, to,
to readers that these are not necessarily
reliable, uh, findings and it's,
it's pretty, it's pretty sobering. And
journalists also tend not to report the,
Oh, by the way, that study who
told you about three years ago,
it turned out not to be
true. Partly because, uh,
those sort of follow on studies tend to
be published in journals that are lower
ranked. They're not the big
flashy journals that send
out press releases and draw
attention to themselves.
So we don't necessarily even see
those followup studies or if we do,
it is kind of a funny storyline to say,
Hey,
do you remember s stretch
way back in your memory?
And remember three years ago we were
talking about genes for, for autism. Well,
nevermind that wasn't right. So, so
these, so you don't hear the, the, the,
the studies that they come along and take.
Yeah. Nevermind. Nothing to see here.
So at any rate,
what's going on here?
I'm going to go give you a quick
survey of the sorts of things that are
happening and going to focus in this,
talk on for them, bad ingredients,
a dubious design of experiments,
statistical errors, uh, that,
that are the crop up quite commonly.
And then some of the funding pressures,
as you might imagine from
looking at the initial graph,
you could appreciate that, uh, that's
creating a bad culture in, in science.
And I want to talk first about, uh,
uh, bad ingredients in this case cells,
a cell lines. This is a book that
was actually written in 1986. Uh,
about, uh, a woman named Henrietta lacks
familiar name, the issues. She was a,
she's now a featured
in an in new HBO story.
Her cervical cancer cells were
or isolated and cultured in a,
at the Johns Hopkins Hospital in 1951.
And they became the first
human cell line of, uh, uh,
that are used as a tremendous
tool for studying cancer,
cervical cancer in particular,
but used in generally just as
perpetual cancer cells. And, uh,
this book is about the fact that those
cells actually ended up getting a very
widely distributed. And, and, uh,
as far as the 19 set back as the 1970s,
a scientist started to realize that they
were contaminating all sorts of other
cell lines that grew like weeds.
Nobody could quite tell.
They had thought they had
isolated other cell lines,
but in fact very frequently they were,
they were studying, he lost cells. Uh,
and there's now a list of
451 contaminated cell lines.
And if you go to the list of says,
you think you're studying this,
if you're using this cell line, guess
what? You're studying something else.
And sometimes you're not
even studying human cells.
You may be studying rat cells.
But if the of this list
of 450 plus cell lines,
more than 100 of them are
Hilo cells. Actually. So this,
this thing has just spread like crazy.
And this book is about the frustrating
efforts of one particular science
scientist named Walter Nelson Reese to
go out and tell his colleagues, hey,
watch out. You're not studying what you're
thinking. You're studying. Be careful.
Take a look at yourselves, make sure
you're, you're know what you're doing.
And he died in a, it's in
frustration because scientists said,
yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever.
And they continue to use
these contaminated cell lines.
And there, there are many, many others.
One of the favorite stories that I have
all along this lines is a cell line that
came out of MD Anderson Hospital in 1976.
It's called MDA MB four 35.
And it was a cell line
that the scientists had.
I isolated from a woman who had breast
cancer, 31 year old woman who uh, uh, and,
and they collected the cells
and they grew up the cell line.
It became one of the most
celebrated cell lines.
It was the national cancer institute
sort of has a list of 60 critical cell
lines that are sort of
archetypal sell ons,
the for cancer of all of all varieties.
And this was on that list of 60,
and I'm considered a really important
saw line for studying breast cancer.
And uh, in the year 2000, uh,
some scientists at Stanford said,
let's take a close look at the NCI 60
a and s and look at gene expression in
these cells,
which is seeing,
look at each so on and say what genes
are turned on and turned off in each of
these cell lines and see if we see
some patterns. And Lo and behold,
they found that the lung cancer cells
all had the same sort of set of genes,
certain set of genes turned
on or there's turned off.
Same was true of melanoma cells.
They were, you know, there was a,
a nice pattern of gene
expression in these cells.
And when they got to this breast cancer
cell, it was like, wait a second,
that gene expression pattern does not
match the other breast cancer cells.
It actually has the same gene expression
pattern as in fact one of the other
melanoma cell lines in, in the collection.
And they put a notice up on the,
on the NCI website saying, Hey,
attention folks, uh, this is,
this was misidentified cell line. This
is, it looks like a melanoma, not a, uh,
not a breast cancer at all. And
since, since the year 2000 Iu, uh,
there's still have been hundreds and
hundreds of papers published of this cell
on referring to it as a
breast cancer cell line.
People haven't been paying
attention. Uh, they're,
they're not finding or paying attention
to the warnings that this is a
misidentified cell line.
So it's a, it's a crazy,
it's a crazy circumstance out there.
And now there are a effective
tests that are inexpensive.
You can take your cell lines,
mail them off to a lab and have them to
have them verified to find out if they
are what, what you
think they are. And, uh,
it was only last year that the NIH said,
if you're getting NIH funding,
we expect you to do that. So
let's hope this problem is
being resolved. But, uh, uh,
remains to be seen how many people
are following through on that dictum.
So that was bad ingredients.
This is bad.
This illustrates bad experimental design.
This data actually comes from, uh,
from, uh, the outfit called the
als therapy development institute,
which is in your neighborhood
right around the corner.
And what they did was they noticed
that many, many drugs for als,
Lou Gehrig's disease weren't working
in, in people. And the question is why.
And so some years ago they went back to
look at the original underlying mouse
studies that had been done to that,
that suggested that these drugs were good.
And the blue bars show increased
survival in the mouse studies for these
original studies.
But the folks at als Tdi recognize that
a lot of these studies were very poorly
designed. That is very few mice.
They, uh, the, the results were,
uh,
you know,
really there's so much noise that they
weren't really believing what they were
seeing.
So they ran all of those experiments
with substantial number of mice watching
them, making sure they got
the sex of the mice right,
that the genetics were correct and so on.
And the black bar show
what they ended up with.
And as you can see almost nothing,
uh,
it worked at all in, in mice, uh,
when the mouse tests were done
correctly. And this is this, there's,
this is a very common problem in,
in biomedicine.
And one reason is that the,
uh,
the als TDI studies each cost well
over a hundred thousand dollars to run.
And if you're a university lab,
you don't have that kind of
money to run a single experiment.
So you run a small experiment. You say,
this is a pilot study. Fingers crossed.
It means what it would mean if we actually
did it with, you know, 32 mice in a,
in a,
in a cohort as opposed to five or 10,
which is what the universities
tend to use. So, so this is a, uh,
this is, uh, an issue that is driven
both by financial pressures and just by,
you know, people hoping for the
best when they're doing experiments.
But I think it's one of the
grave concern about how much, uh,
we're really getting out of these, uh,
biomedical research labs if they're,
you know, trying to do the
best they can on the cheap.
It doesn't necessarily pan out.
And the, and you know, these,
these experiments cost many millions of
dollars to run once they got to human
beings. And essentially none
of these drugs work, uh,
that the top drug has a very minor effect,
but it's nothing to get excited about.
And all the rest of them,
you know,
tens of millions of dollars have been
spent on each of those studies or many of
those studies at any rate. And they
were all bused. So, uh, so, uh,
the folks at als Tdi
are now trying to say,
let's do the careful experiments first.
Let's run these,
let's spend the couple of
hundred thousand dollars upfront.
And if we find good stuff, then we
can move forward. But let's, let's,
let's be a little bit more cautious with
our preclinical research before we take
it into human beings. Uh, this guy,
I've got lots of stories
about Keith Bagherli,
his a biostatistician at
MD Anderson in Houston,
but I'll just tell one
story about a ovarian cancer
tests that he discovered was
a rather inappropriately
put on the market. Uh,
it had been discovered by,
uh,
actually the scientists at
the NCI and at the FDA. They,
instead of looking for sort of your
standard molecule that would indicate the
presence of ovarian cancer, uh, they said,
let's try a different approach
because that had, that had failed.
And what they did was they
used a mass spectrometer,
which sort of looks at the masses
of various part of particles.
And we'll look at the
spectrum of mass of these, uh,
of these proteins in the blood
from women with ovarian cancer.
And women who don't have ovarian cancer
and see if we can see some sort of
different in that could be a powerful
new test. And they announced, hey,
we found something that's really
works great. Uh, actually, uh,
folks in Congress passed a resolution
saying this is fabulous work,
keep it up in 2002 and a,
and Keith Bagley and his colleagues
at MD Anderson tried to do it,
couldn't get it to work. And
finally back, uh, Bagherli said,
let me go back and look
at the original data.
And what he noticed was all of the women
with ovarian cancer had their tests run
on one particular day and the
controls were run on a different day.
And then she was just tuned differently
on what from one day to the other.
So this was, this is a example of what
scientists called the batch of fact.
And this is another problem that that
keeps cropping up in biomedical research.
Uh, and uh, and that's pretty,
pretty shocking that, uh,
that that test got so far
along before people realized,
Oh, this is just, you know,
completely false lead. Uh, another, uh,
statistical problem is called Harking,
which is hypothesizing
after the results are known,
it sounds like fairly innocent
thing to do. You Run an experiment,
you don't get the results
you expect, but you say, oh,
but that's an unexpected result. I'm going
to say that was my hypothesis. And, uh,
you know,
that this gene is associated with the
cancer that I wasn't expecting it to be.
It turns out most of the time those
results are wrong. And, uh, uh, just,
just by nature of the kind of statistics
that people apply to those, the,
the p values and so on, the
whole statistical mechanism,
it's perfectly good to,
to do an experiment like that and to say,
uh,
I've generated a new hypothesis in the
study and now I'm going to go test it in
a new one.
But it's really inappropriate
and unfortunately very
common for scientists to
say, look at the results
I found. This is, this is,
here's my new hypothesis and
here's data that support it.
So it's another reason that,
uh,
there's actually a famous paper written
by a guy named John John Ian eds,
who's at Stanford,
who,
who has a paper titled Why most
published research findings are false.
And this is, uh, this is fundamentally
part of the reason for that. Uh,
also, uh, behavior in, in,
in science because of this
funding pressures. Uh,
scientists are pressured to cut corners.
They know that if they don't
publish their papers in the, in the,
in the top journals, they're unlikely to
get more grants or promotions and so on.
So there's huge incentives for people to,
you know,
leave out the data that doesn't quite
help them tell their story or to, to,
you know,
to just to nudge things around here.
And this is a study from
the national academies.
It just came out a couple of weeks ago,
uh,
looking at these issues more
broadly about scientific integrity.
And this is a follow up from a study that
was done 25 years ago where the focus
was on scientists who, uh, sort
of the bad apples, if you will,
looking at the actually fairly rare cases
of outright fraud and misconduct that,
uh, that is, uh, responsible for some
of these cases, but not all that many.
And they said, we're, we're
looking differently at this. Now.
When I talked to one of the panelists,
a CK can sailors who said we'd been
fond of the bad apple narrative,
and now we're talking about switching
to the barrels and the barrel makers.
In other words, trying to understand
the system that is setting people up to,
to act appropriately, to, you
know, to shave, to, to make,
to do questionable research practices.
These are not outright fraud,
but there are things that
you know, that are, that are,
that are questionable and that are
detrimental to the progress of research.
So that's a, that's another very
significant and hard to measure a problem.
But,
uh,
but there have been a couple of surveys
and exploration's of that and uh,
it's clearly part of the underwrite
an underlying problem here.
So solutions validating ingredients.
I already mentioned that now
there's this easy test for example,
to send off your cell
lines and get them tested.
Scientists are expected to do that.
It's only a year old.
I'm really interested to see whether
people are following up on that and I hope
I've hoped to find out,
but I don't know yet.
Transparency of making your
data and your code available.
I think this is an idea that's
getting a lot of traction.
We'll talk a little more about that.
Better training for scientists.
Very often scientists just learn from
the mentors and they don't necessarily
realize that what they're doing is,
is detrimental to their, uh, to their,
to what they're doing. And uh,
and if they had better training,
maybe they would know more.
And finally finding some way to use
this financial crunch because that's the
underlying pressure
that's driving a lot of,
this is my favorite story
about transparency. Uh,
this is a paper published. The, the, the,
the first draft of the human genome
published in nature in February,
2001 this was a, you know, a milestone
in biological research, uh, in,
in science in general. And, uh,
and instead of publishing the entire 3
billion base pair code of DNA and in a,
in nature, what they did was to say, well,
we're highlighting about a dozen or so
sort of exciting and unexpected findings.
And one of them was they reported finding
dozens of genes that were bacterial
genes right in our human genome. And they
thought, that's weird. How could that be?
It's really interesting how,
how could bacterial genes
jumped into the human genome?
And the answer was they
didn't, uh, Steven Salzberg,
who was at the Institute for
Genome Research, uh, at the time,
and some of his colleagues said,
I don't believe this is true,
but the genome data were
all publicly available,
a completely transparent and
Salzburg and his colleague said,
let's do our own analysis.
They pulled it the same day to sit down.
They looked it over and they had a
completely different explanation for those
apparently microbial genes in the
genome. And they said, false alarm guys,
this isn't, this didn't happen. So,
and this is, this was in June of 2001.
It was just a few months later. It
was really quite a remarkable, uh, uh,
uh, feedback loop for, for getting
results either verified or,
or not verified in this case.
And I think this is an incredibly
powerful example of how transparency can,
can work and can really help resolve
these questions much more rapidly.
Scientists of course,
guard their data jealously.
They are concerned that
there'll be scooped,
that their intellectual property will
be whisked away by other scientists.
And so those are very real issues.
And I don't mean to minimize them,
but it is also true that to the extent
that you can get people to put their data
up,
their code up and to,
and to share their ingredients when
asked than other scientists can,
can rapidly come around and say, this is
working. Is this right? Is this right?
Is this wrong?
And I also think that if you know that
any that you have that much transparency
in what you've done,
maybe just take a little more time to,
to fact check it yourself and make sure
that if there are problems that you find
it before your, before your, uh,
your, uh, your colleagues do.
So I think that's a really powerful idea.
And I think the new culture,
the culture of, of, uh,
that comes out of your world of open
source and so on, I think has really led,
uh, I think the younger
generation to appreciate this
and to be less resistant to
sharing. And I, I think that's a positive
long term trend in, in biomedicine.
But, uh, it will, it will not just
sweep through the field overnight,
but I think it would be very
salutary in terms of education.
This is a wonderful scientist
named Arturo Casa Duvall,
who's at Johns Hopkins now and,
uh,
and it's his view that basically the
educational system needs to be reformed.
And, uh, there are essentially no growth,
good methodology classes
anywhere in biomedicine. Uh,
you sort of learn from your mentor
and if your mentor is Great,
you learned a great technique and
if your mentor is not so good,
well maybe you learn good laboratory
technique but you don't necessarily learn
how to think, how to, how to sort of
think through problems and how to,
how to deal with some of these broader
issues. So constant of all is uh,
trying to think about how to retool a
science education and he's by far not
alone. There are lots of other
people thinking about that.
Want to just end the talk talking about
four people who I think have really
interesting ideas. Uh, these are, uh,
the first two are Carolyn
Compton and Anna Barker who are,
we're both at the national cancer
institute and are now at Arizona State
University. And Dr. Compton is a
pathologist and she noticed that,
that that uh,
tissues collected either for blood or
organ cancer tissue and so on is collected
in a very willy nilly manner. And,
and everyone does it differently.
No one thinks very much about
how long it has to sit around,
how quickly it gets preserved, when
it gets frozen, when it gets or, or,
or preserved with, fix it
over, whatever. And uh,
and she realized that as we're moving
into the world of personalized medicine,
if you're not doing collecting that
material in a very uniform way,
you're going to end up with a lot of
variation that is going to be misleading.
And so she's been working really hard
with pathologist to get them to develop
and use uniform standards for tissue
collection so that when we start diving
into this data, we can actually have some
faith that there's at least that, that,
that very important source of, of, uh,
variation is limited by careful
collecting of tissue. Uh,
her colleague and a barker is sort of
taking the whole idea of reproducibility
and, and a very rigorous approach
to, she's applying to, uh,
studies of Glioblastoma,
a very difficult to treat brain cancer.
And she sort of starting from the very
beginning and going all the way through
clinical trials of Glioblastoma to say
we're going to do every single step as
rigorously as we possibly can. And I
said, why did you choose Glioblastoma?
It's one of the hardest
cancers to cure brain cancer.
That that essentially is as a death
sentence almost always. And she said,
well if I can make it
work with Glioblastoma,
people will have to sit up and pay
attention. So that experiment is,
it was just going into the clinical
trials right now and it could be very
interesting to see whether,
I think it's an uphill battle for her,
but if she can make work that
would be really quite remarkable.
The final two guys I want to talk about
our Steve Goodman and John Ian who are
at the Meta research innovation
center at Stanford metrics.
And their idea basically is we need to
study how science is being conducted.
This is the metal research of research
in order to understand why all of these
things come up and,
and what kind of solutions we can
come up with to resolve them. And
they were both veterans of actually
addressing this very similar set of issues
that came up with a human
based medicine in the 1990s.
Many of the clinical trials that were
done back in that era or done, uh,
with very poor record,
they were,
they were not put together with s with
as much care and caution as they are
today by no means perfect,
but w but scientists are now thinking
much more carefully about sample sizes,
about controls,
about making sure that they're
avoiding bias as much as possible and,
and avoiding things like, uh, like
hypothesizing after the results are known,
which is a huge problem in biomedical
research and one tool that has been put to
use and it's quite successful,
um,
at least in addressing some of these
issues as a website called the clinical
trials.gov if you're a scientist and
you want to develop a new drug and do a
clinical trial on human beings,
you have to put your data or you have
to register in advance on clinical
trials.gov you have to say in
advance what your hypothesis is.
So if you come up with findings
that support some other hypothesis,
you have to admit that wasn't my
hypothesis and these results are not to be
taken literally. But, uh,
and you also need to post your results
once you've finished your study,
uh,
to make sure that you're not just sort
of hiding results that are disappointing
cause the biomedical literature is, uh,
is skewed in terms of results that are,
that are positive results.
People who find things that aren't,
that don't work out tend not to spend
the time to publish them. They'd may not,
it may just be the effort involved in
putting it together or whatever. But the,
uh, but a lot, but the, as a result,
when someone goes to survey
the literature and say, well,
how many studies show this is true and
how many don't they get a very skewed
sample. And, and so, uh, this,
a website is designed to,
to, to at least encourage scientists to
publish their results, uh, to get a more,
a more well rounded sample of that.
Many scientists unfortunately
still are not publishing a posting.
The results in here as is required by law.
But at least you know that when you
go there and say no results found, uh,
that you can see, you can at least
know that there, there was a study,
there were results and uh,
and if you really care about doing
a Meta analysis or something, uh,
you better track him down. Uh, so at least
you know that they exist even if you,
even if they aren't
public. So at any rate, um,
I wanted to end on that note because
I think that it really is, um,
I mean there are things that can
be done and there are patterns.
There are examples from the past of taking
similar issues in reproducibility and
finding ways to, to improve the
systems. And it's, you know,
the scientists who are doing this don't
want to spend their careers, you know,
wasting their time and coming
up with results that aren't,
that aren't pushing science forward.
So I think the best news is
that scientists would like
this problem to be solved.
And the problem is with the financial
pressures and all the rest of that,
the system is still not set up
to help them succeed. And so, uh,
and those are hard problems to
solve. Obviously you, you're,
you can't double the amount of
money in it, the Nh again, or are,
you can't ask half the people who are,
uh,
who are currently doing this kind of
research to leave and find some other kind
of line of work.
So they're very difficult issues to solve,
but that people are thinking about at
least how to make some improvements along
along the way.
And,
and there's still a group of people
thinking about how we can solve the
underlying problem. I think that's the
hardest one of all. But I think, uh,
I think that the fact that
people want to do good work,
I think really helps,
uh,
helps us move forward with
this and having the support,
at least current of the
current leadership of the Nih,
I think also really helps provide
a path forward, at least for,
for some of these. So, yeah,
at any rate at this point would
be delighted to Dick Questions.
Thanks for your attention.
Okay.
So I, I have a quick, uh,
kind of something that I thought of
as you were giving the talk that, uh,
okay,
much, uh, in, in the Internet pass there
was always this a question of like,
if you go look for a particular reseller,
do you know that they're
actually like providing hue?
The things are advertising and a,
it was an early problem and uh,
some clever people put together a
site that collected stories about each
reseller. So if you found someone, you
kind of had to go to sites and says, okay,
was there ever any follow up on
this? You know, was this happen?
Is there something like that
going on maybe for, you know,
this backlog of research papers,
cause I know there's not a
lot of retractions that ever
reached the light of day,
but if you're searching in the past for,
you know,
some promising research,
it's kind of hard to follow the trail of,
you know,
how did that ever Pan out?
It is difficult. And I,
and one example I encountered in my book
is there was a study that was linking
gene expression, uh, and comparing
it between races and uh, and,
and it was a paper that the asserted
that there was a very large difference in
gene expression between Caucasians and
Asians and other scientists looked at the
data and we're were highly critical of it.
And they were able to publish a paper
in a completely different literature.
I think it was nature methods
or something like that,
which is not the human genetics
literature, but it was, you know,
in the scientific literature. And
they said, we found these flaws.
The scientists sort of responded and said,
yeah we did screw up a little bit, we,
you know, whatever. But that whole
discussion took place off to the side.
If you want to go and find it in
the medical literature you can.
But there's still like hundreds and
hundreds of papers that site the original
research and have no idea that this
discussion has taken place cause they were
just looking in the, in the genetics
literature or whatever. So it's a,
it's a very big problem of sort
of hide and seek if you will.
There's actually a tool that has,
that has come up that is helping this
a little bit, which is a, um, uh,
called pub here,
which is a basically an open
comments site that if you,
and you can post comments about anything
you read in the literature and, uh,
and I have an APP on my browser
that lets me, that alerts me.
If I go to a page that has, this,
has this paper, it'll alert me.
There are six comments about
this paper on pub pier. So,
so there are tools that are starting
to be used to do that, but it's a,
or if there's some similar system in a,
in,
if you go to the NIH, the National
Library of medicine's database,
they have a pub Med and
comments at pub med.
And so you can see comments there.
The difference being the pub
med comments are not anonymous,
so people are a little bit more, uh, a
little less likely to engage their pub.
Here. You can be anonymous
so it can also be, you know,
be a little spicier as you can imagine
for anonymous comments. But yeah, it is a,
it is a huge information
flow problem that,
that scientists are
starting to chip away at.
But there's a huge room
for improvement for sure.
So one of the points he made,
or a couple I guess you said one is
that some of this bad science is being
shaped by pressure from a lack of funding.
And so I think by implication if funding
were more readily available than maybe
there'd be less bad science. And at the
same time you said, well I can't ask,
you know,
if you can't double the budget,
you also can't ask caps
the people to leave.
But I really want to question that because
it seems that we can either trust and
reverify that the public money we put
into science now is generating genuine
science. A lot of it's bogus and we
don't even know which parts are how much.
And there are certainly bad actors.
Some of them are very,
very influential in fact.
And some of them are known in the
community and some of them have,
have concealed themselves, you
know, more effectively so far.
And that's a huge problem. So the idea
that putting more money in to as a,
it's a situation that's
generating bad science,
it seems like throwing good money after
bad. And at the same time saying, well,
we can't ask half the people to leave.
Well if half of them are bad actors,
maybe we should. Except I would argue with
it. I wouldn't, let me push back. Oh go.
I'm sorry. But let me, let me
go on to the people at large,
the public at large who elect
the officials. You know, the,
the government that sets the public policy
around this are furthermore not well
informed because of the media celebrates
splashy findings even when they turn
out to be bogus. And there are many
famous example of, for example,
step is often talked about here,
um,
and does not pursue with
the same sort of vigor,
the sort of investigative journalists
love finding scandals at City Hall.
But as you point out,
there are these studies done in humans
with hundreds of millions of dollars and
so on and so forth where there
was some really shady or shaky,
let's say preclinical work beforehand
and this waste doesn't seem to be exposed
to the same kind of vigor.
So I'm sort of curious about
your response to those thoughts.
Yeah, good. Good questions. And I
think first of all, uh, there are,
I think if you look at actual cases of
outright fraud, the really bad actors,
they're fairly,
they're fairly small number of people who
are clearly just gaming the system who
are, who are doing, who are
deliberately misleading and so on.
I think the vast majority
of these problems are well
meaning scientists who, uh,
who ended up taking shortcuts that they
shouldn't have the using too few mice or,
or, or not really following
their procedures and so on.
And so you can't say get rid of all
the bad apples. Cause many of you know,
I have a story in the book about a
Nobel laureate scientist who made it,
who has a paper that was wrong.
And she was like,
I was a pressure to publish situation,
but you wouldn't want to tell her, sorry,
you're out of science now. She, you know,
she was, has contributed a lot since then.
So everyone can make these mistakes and
missteps in the end depending on the
pressures and the circumstances.
So it's not just a simply a matter
of weeding out the bad actors.
It's changing the culture and telling
people maybe you should publish,
you should be rewarded for
publishing less and making,
taking more time to make sure what you do.
Publish is right. The pressure's right.
Now actually there's a paper
that suggests that uh, the,
the evolutionary pressures in science
are the favor of the labs that churn out
the most stuff the fastest. And, and,
and, uh, and they replicate these, these,
these labs then spin off, uh, you
know, their Grad students going,
postdocs go on start labs that
use the same, you know, you know,
fast matters most and in generate
large volumes of paper. So,
so you can change the culture too to
discourage that without, you know,
firing the people who are, who are, who
are doing things that you know, are, are,
are clearly wrong, but they are
clearly not helpful either. So it's,
it's a hard problem how,
how to get at it for sure.
Thanks for coming today.
Um,
so I know that in manufacturing
specifically there's a
large focus on quality
control. Um, and again, healthcare
isn't my field personally.
Um, so maybe there's an
obvious answer to this,
but I'm curious to know if there's
anything to be learned or if there's any
surveying that you did have the business
community on how they've improved
quality control,
whether it's actually assigning
quality control officers or empowering
individuals to take a closer look at
quality. Um, are there any lessons there?
There are for sure.
Cause I think industry,
the drug industry and Pharma and so it
tends to do much better at these problems
because they,
their incentive structure is completely
different if they do something,
if you're in, if you're in academia,
you're reward is getting a paper in a,
you know, big name journals.
That's, that's your reward.
It doesn't matter so much
if it's right or wrong.
If you're at a drug company
that does it, that's nice, but,
but what you really want to do
is have a product you can sell.
And so the drug companies care a lot more
about making sure that the quality is
high.
And there are some people who argue that
you should take that degree of rigor
that already exists in,
in Pharma and tell people in academia
we expect you to follow something like
this or have some similar
set of standards to do that.
And it would slow them down.
It would, you know, uh, it's,
it's a little bit more cumbersome, but
I think you get, you get better output,
you get better results for doing that.
And there's some universities that have
sort of found a middle ground, pardon me,
they are, uh, letting the
academics be academics,
but before the science goes forward,
they then bring it into a lab where
we're s we're scientists who are sort of
like, look at it from the standpoint
of drug development and say,
let's see if we can
validate these results.
If we can reproduce them before
we start sending them out, uh, to,
to Pharma and so on.
So some,
there are some fairly inexpensive ways
that universities can create these
research units that help, uh,
sort of crank up the quality.
But clearly, I mean, Pharma knows how
to do this, uh, but it's, you know,
it's a different,
different world in academia.
Hi. So earlier you mentioned how
a pipe paper can be published,
it can make a big splash and they're
turning out to be problems with the paper.
Maybe it's,
you know,
its conclusions aren't as true as they
look and it can be very hard to find
those sorts of,
the criticisms of it.
What can a tool like Google scholar
do to make those sorts of things,
those like those followup easier to find?
Hmm. Um, a lie. If I would look at the,
the pub pier example, because I think
that's a, I think that is a useful tool.
Uh, just for, cause you have to,
you rely on individuals who flagged a
paper and either have published something
that's kind of contradictory or at least
published a comment someplace that says,
I don't think this is right and
raises questions about it. Uh,
I don't know how Google scholar could,
could sort of index those, those cautions
in a, you know, in a fruitful way,
but as opposed to just reporting it
842 citations. Well that doesn't,
that is not as informative to me as
it would be 842 of which 30 strongly
disagree and you know, and the
others we don't know about. So,
so a tool like that that would
help not only say who is cited it,
but what they have,
uh,
what they have observed about those
papers in a general sense I think could be
very useful.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
I just had a quick question at looking
at these studies from a different angle.
I know a lot of,
we've talked about here are the tests
to try to find cures and what works and
what doesn't work.
And the other side is,
is the test to either prove what is
happening or what's causing these in the
first place to find it, how to prevent
the disease from coming. Um, and,
and I went through work,
I guess going through a personal
scenario where I found out my,
my house is gonna be on the corner of
a high voltage power line with two,
I have two little kids in the house.
So I dove into every single study on
EMS and the links to charter leukemia.
And it started to,
to see that anytime that you found a
promising study that showed this land corp
even didn't show us link,
it's very easy for the other sides are
poking holes in it because the sample
size and,
and I'm just wondering from your opinion,
how do you look at the other side
from like we started looking at the
precautionary principle
and stuff like that,
but to actually prevent
these when you have other,
what they were calling hired scientists
to kind of poke holes in these studies
that there very well may be
actual holes in the study,
but then it's going to prevent us from
ever taking that step to actually prevent
some of these diseases from taking form.
Yeah.
And unfortunately those are all,
most of those studies are
epidemiological studies,
which are much harder to get to try to
ground truth because you have so many
variables you're working with.
It's not working in a laboratory
situation where you can reproduce these
experiments and so on. So
yeah, that's uh, that's,
I mean the quality,
just the outright quality if to begin
with is fairly low on those. So a,
and that confidence should be,
yeah, it should be low in those, uh,
it's uh,
yeah.
How does, how to sort through that
and find the truth is, is tough.
I mean the IOM in the case
of the EMS and power lines,
there was a big national research council,
a National Academy of Science's report
I think some years ago where they took,
they took another run at these issues and
based on the first decade or two of us
of studies on this and they said there
doesn't really seem to be anything here.
Uh,
and I think in that case we stepped back
and when we rely on expert opinion as
opposed to a really expecting that
the science will yield us a completely
concrete and believable answer, it's
not totally satisfactory, but, um,
but eh, but I, that's, I think given the,
given the realities of that kind of
science, I think that that's kind of what,
where we're left with is what,
what is the expert opinion on this?
Yeah.
Concerning reproducibility.
I have thought that reproducing results
is theoretically important for science
to work,
but unlikely to be actually done in
practice very much because I doubt that
anyone gets a Nobel prize or even tenure
at the lower train switch community
college for redoing something as
someone already didn't publish.
You've told a few stories of people
actually trying to reproduce results.
So clearly this happens
at least sometimes.
Do you have any general observations
concerning the cases when it actually
happens?
If someone tries to reproduce the result,
what were the motivations typically?
What's the distribution of reasons that
caused someone to actually bother to do
this? Yeah, I think most common motivation
is a,
if you're working in a,
in a rival lab and you're a postdoc or
graduate student and your professor says,
Hey, there's an exciting finding there,
see if you can build on that result,
but before you build on it,
make sure it's correct.
And so that's where I think a lot of
the reproducibility these attempts to
reproduce happen is at the
bench. People saying, I want to,
I want to take this on and I want
to see if it actually works. And uh,
and so this people can waste,
you know,
six months or a year of their
career chasing something that,
that that doesn't pan out, but at least
they've done the attempt to reproduce.
And sometimes that gets published
and people realize, oops,
this didn't really work. And sometimes
it doesn't. I mean, for some big results,
you were mentioning the report of be
at some amazing new way to produce stem
cells. That was such a big finding that,
um, that everyone realized if that's a,
if that's for real, that's an incredibly
important laboratory tools. So, you know,
dozens and dozens of blabs
dived into that to see,
can we make this work and can we
start using it ourselves? So, uh, so,
so there are some very strong motivations
and they tend to be motivated to do
those studies that are the
most interesting. So that,
I'm sure there's tons of stuff in the
literature that somebody publishes.
It just becomes a line on their CV and
that's it. Nobody ever looks at it again.
And it's kind of just disappears into the,
uh,
into the dust and nobody really notices.
And those are some ways,
it doesn't matter if
those ones work or not,
but the exciting and interesting finding
sis suggestions of a new direction and
so on,
those studies do get attention and people
do sit down and try to reproduce them.
Sometimes it can take a long time though.
I've a story in my book, um, about, uh,
example of this was a discovery
1999, 2000 called, uh,
it was regarding a phenomena they
called trans differentiation,
which was a couple of labs reported that
they discovered they could take blood
cells, uh, uh,
bone marrow cells and transform them into
any other kinds of cells they wanted,
which was like sort of, that would be
incredibly powerful laboratory tool.
And people took off on this idea of the,
of trans differentiating these blood
cells, uh, to do it. And they, uh,
and there were quite a number of studies
published before somebody at Stanford
finally said,
wait a second,
all these studies that are reporting on
it and people are doing this and so on.
But no one has really done the careful
reproduction of this experiment or,
or really tried to get to the bottom of
whether it's a really correct phenomenon.
And they did a series of very
time consuming, elaborate,
technically challenging and really careful
experiments and concluded the whole
thing was, was a mirage. It was
actually not really happening. And uh,
and there's a, and so, and this was,
it only took about three
or four years I guess,
before they published this paper and said,
guess what?
The fluorescent marker you're seeing
means something completely different.
It has nothing to do with the
cells changing cell types.
It's just moving around.
And, uh, and the entire field sort
of disappeared like a soap bubble.
But there were, there were many,
many studies that had been published,
reporting seemingly validated in this
phenomenon before this lab at Stanford
said, wait a second, no one's really
done the careful validation here it is.
And guess what? It doesn't
work. So, so sometimes it,
sometimes it takes a little while to
sort out. Uh, I just had one question.
You mentioned you had looked at
medicine earlier on in your career.
Like in the early two thousands,
was any of this stuff on your radar then?
No, actually. And uh,
I mean a lot of the problems in clinical
medicine with clinical trials and so on,
uh,
that had been regarded as significant
problems at that time got very little
attention in the media. I think a lot of
this sort of happened below the radar.
I mean,
I,
there was maybe some of it written
up in some of the technical journals,
but this was not an issue that really
garner public attention. And,
uh, and I think some of these,
these, these new stories were,
were surprising to people,
but because the results were so
eye-popping and a lot of the,
a lot of the clinical research stuff
was much more along the lines of, well,
we know that the drug companies always
like to look at their results in the best
possible light to try to
get their FDA approval.
And so there's always this element of,
of,
of knowledge that things are always being
interpreted in, in ways that are, uh,
not necessarily just
completely straight forward.
But I don't think there was
an awareness about how, uh,
how much improvement was needed
in the world of clinical research,
at least not in the lay press.
All right.
Thank you all for coming.